thanks for joining us here at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis our
top story tonight a young
las vegas woman fighting in the hospital
after her family says she suffered a
severe reaction
to johnson and johnson's covid vaccine
now this is one of six very rare
instances where blood clots have formed
in or near the brain after getting that
shot
oracle mana joining us now live with the
latest on this local case
orgo well denise and brian 18 year old
emma berkey is described as kind
loving and full of faith she's
recovering in the hospital right now
and loved ones hope the power of prayer
helped her pull through
she's a young woman with a bright future
ahead of her loved ones say 18 year old
los vegan emma berkey had a serious
reaction to the johnson and johnson kova
19 vaccine earlier this month some brain
clots were starting to form
speaking on behalf of the berkey family
walk church pastor haydn ratner tells me
emma was taken to a california hospital
in an induced coma and underwent three
brain surgeries
the good news she's making progress
she's responding some
to cues from her parents and the doctors
she's breathing on her own we've been
seeing some miracles
throughout this journey but we believe
there's still more to come emma is one
of six women across the country who have
reportedly experienced severe blood
clots after getting the johnson and
johnson vaccine making it a one in a
million occurrence
it's very very rare the j vaccine has
been put on hold
while researchers look more into it but
dr mark j khan says when it comes back
we should not be afraid
we know that if you get an active covet
infection your risk of clotting may be
as high as two or three percent
so the risk benefit for the even the j j
vaccine
strongly favors getting vaccinated
rattner says people should make informed
decisions about the vaccine and he's
asking the community to continue praying
for emma
we have optimistic faith we're praying
for better days ahead
now we've confirmed emma is a senior at
coral academy of science las vegas in a
statement
the school's executive director said in
part quote we are heartbroken yet pledge
our support to the family during this
difficult time we've also made on-campus
resources readily available
for those who knew that know the student
and need assistance
during this time now a gofundme page has
also been set up
to help pay for emma's hospital bills we
have a link to that on our website
8newsnow.com
live in the newsroom tonight orca mana 8
news now